[Musica]
[Applauso]
oggi sono qui per parlarvi delle mogi sì
avete sentito bene quelle faccine che
oramai non sono più solo una sorta di
protesi dei nostri messaggi bensì ne
hanno acquisito piena padronanza
se pensate che siano solo un
abbellimento o forse che so il ghirigoro
alla retorica di ogni nostra
conversazione
allora vi sbagliate ho condotto
un'indagine nella mia scuola apre su un
campione di 100 ragazzi dai 14 ai 19
anni ho chiesto
secondo voi le emoji servono a
differenziare sono i messaggi
il 70 per cento mi ha detto di sì invece
il cento per cento
mi ha detto di preferire i messaggi
accompagnati dai magi anche voi come me
lo riuscite più a farne a meno
sono giunto alla conclusione che queste
faccine così simpatiche e colloquiali
sono talmente entrate nella nostra
quotidianità che è impossibile
immaginarci l'essenza mi sono chiesta
cosa è che ci spinge a farne un uso così
frequente in primis
ho cercato di dare una definizione a
questo fenomeno
il primo aggettivo che mi è venuto in
mente è stato travolgente il dizionario
treccani si dice che travolgente
significa che travolge che abbatte ogni
resistenza quindi forte irresistibile
dunque ho pensato che o cos'altro ci può
dare l'idea di qualcosa di travolgente
la prima immagine che mi è venuta in
mente è stata una
di uno smaltimento di una frana come
esempio la frana e di vasto del 1956
mi sono detta che anche un discorso di
retorica può essere travolgente se non
ammetti nessuno che lo controbatta come
esempio nel film altri tempi in cui
vittorio de sica pronuncia un abile
discorso di oratoria che ammutolisce la
sala anche una passione amorosa può
dirti travolgente come è rappresentata
in maniera vivida l'abbraccio di egon
schiele dunque nella nostra società così
rapida rapace razionale le magie hanno
proprio colto nel segno
queste sono nate agli inizi degli anni
80 per distinguere i messaggi ironici da
quelli seri e non è tutto ciò che
facciamo ancora oggi possiamo mostrarci
tristi felici arrabbiati compiaciuti
proprio come se fossimo dall'altra parte
dello schermo
d'altronde possiamo anche vincere ma non
è anche quello ciò che facciamo sempre
non c'è lingua che possa dirsi
perfettamente funzionale rispetto alle
esigenze della civiltà moderna nel
francese nel tedesco nel russo nello
spagnolo e neppure l'inglese a darci
queste parole fu italo calvino
agli inizi degli anni 70 credo però che
ci sia un linguaggio che possa
soddisfare come diceva lui le esigenze
della civiltà moderna ma sia quello
delle moggi secondo me la società del
futuro sta proprio nelle voci ma non
come kill e paragona a i geroglifici
egizi
di sicuro l'idea di fondo di
rappresentare le cose con i disegni è la
stessa tuttavia il bacino di utenza
delle moggi non è certamente
paragonabile a quello dei geroglifici
infatti nell'antico egitto pochi
sapevano leggere e scrivere
oggi invece le voci sono usate da
tantissime persone chiunque a un
dispositivo elettronico alle può usare
quindi qui sorge un problema
troppe persone
non e con differenti background
culturali per un unico alfabeto digitale
ad esempio a ri figurare una sposa nelle
moggi abbiamo solo una donna con un
vestito e un velo bianco
tuttavia sappiamo che ad esempio in cina
il colore preponderante è in rosso le
moli oggi non ammettono una faccina che
rappresenti una donna vestita di rosso
questo continuo omologarsi adeguarsi a
un unico canone ha fatto sì che molti
paesi occidentali e non perdessero molte
delle peculiarità che le
caratterizzavano ad esempio anche
l'italia storica fondatrice della
dell'unione europea e componente della
nato se l'è trovata anche lei a non
rispettare più e a non salvaguardare i
più le realtà particolari che si ricorda
un po pier paolo pasolini di sicuro avrà
un idea riguardo penso pensiero
altrimenti vi fornisco io un estratto da
una testata giornalistica del 73 è
cominciato un'opera di omologazione
distruttrice di won densità e
concretezza un edonismo neo laico e
ciecamente dimentico di ogni valore
umanistico e certamente estraneo alle
scienze umane potremmo dire che il suo
pensiero sia stato lungimirante per
alcuni versi sim ma se vogliamo che
questo processo di omologazione si
arresti
dovremo partire da ciò che più nel
concreto samp siamo e quindi perché no
dalle moggi qualcuno potrebbe obiettare
dicendo che questo non è un problema che
vale la pena risolvere ma tutto ciò che
ignoriamo con il tempo andrà sarà molto
più difficile da combattere
dunque nel delegato in testa l'idea di
questa stele di rosetta 2.0
perché non inventare un codice uno
strumento che serva interpretare in
maniera chiara ed efficace tutte le
emoji ad esempio per non sbagliarsi
quando si deve utilizzare le molle
ma le giunte come batti cinque non ti
prego può sapere che non tutte le spose
vestono di bianco come d'altronde hanno
già fatto giustamente con le donne con
il velo e con i componenti della
comunità lgbt per fronteggiare il futuro
secondo me bisognerebbe consolidare il
presente e se quello su cui dobbiamo
lavorare sono le emoji ben venga un
avvenire basato sulla divertita e
sull'arricchimento per rendere granitica
questa società liquida che tanto se
critica se faremo esplodere la forza
delle mo ci andremo incontro a un
progresso che sarà consapevole e
corretto per tutti
d'altronde come farebbero a intendersi
un francese e un giapponese
almeno per sommi capi senza le magìe
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]